خمسة أربعة ثلاثة
اثنان واحد صفر
سيارة اشتعال تنطلق من
نفق دفع واحد منذ لحظات
خنقنا المحركات للأسفل
استعدادًا لحد أقصى q اه أو
أقصى ضغط ديناميكي هوائي
سيشاهده الصاروخ من
أجل الصوت تكون السيارة أسرع من الصوت
ويجب أن نمر من خلاله  max q
هنا في بضع ثوانٍ فقط
[موسيقى]
وصلت السيارة إلى أقصى ضغط ديناميكي هوائي ،
يا له من منظر جميل لتلك المحركات التسعة m1d
التي تحترق هناك في
يوم صافٍ جميل
يمكنك رؤيته في تلك اللقطات الجميلة
التي قمنا للتو
بفصل مرحلة نيكو والمحرك الثاني
بدء التشغيل الأول
، ستخرج زعانف الشبكة هذه في
المرحلة الأولى هناك في المرحلة اليسرى ،
تنشر إحدى ساق الهبوط بشكل
رائع في المنتصف ، وهذا هو
رقمنا الخامس والثمانين للتعافي الناجح
رقم 100 الإطلاق الناجح الثامن عشر